[Music]
when i first came into the area i saw
this piece of land it was right next to
one of the world's best fly fisheries
the henry's fork of the snake river we
jumped right on that piece of property
and started building the lodge
i thought i could fly fish while i had
the phone in my pocket taking
reservations
and that actually happened early on in
the early days in 1999
[Music]
dave would go cut the logs and peel the
logs sometimes he'd make our sons peel
some logs but they were pretty pretty
little
growing up here was something
special
we literally worked every aspect of it i
started out as a little kid doing dishes
and busting tables and then waiting
tables when we finally got the lodge
built and opened we would have like two
hour waits
and people loved it
loved it the lodge was full every single
night it was going so well that they
were getting ready to expand
and then that summer
we lost my little brother he was 10
years old when he died
[Music]
it was
it was dark it was a dark bad time
and my mom
fell
[Music]
out when we lost that little boy
our life
stopped
and i went to bed
for three years
and i didn't i didn't get up
so without her here my dad was forced to
run everything by himself
and that's kind of the way he coped with
everything
there was just a darkness and a sadness
that surrounded our family for years
business is quite slow i'd say it's
probably 25 percent compared to 100
percent back then
david needs some help
that came back about a year ago to help
me run the restaurant and lodge
he sees constantly how it's a struggle
for me to keep up with the restaurant
side so he came back to help
you take a young man you stick him in
there and you put him as a general
manager a general manager in my opinion
is somebody who needs to know the inside
and outside of the whole operation
but he doesn't know these things
dave and i are tired and it's just like
a black hole for us and
we don't want to work this hard anymore
making it come back is our last hope
it's my best hope
[Music]
i've just arrived at island park idaho
and it is absolutely gorgeous this city
is nicknamed last chance because it
literally is the last place to stop for
food gas and lodgings before entering
yellowstone national park
and this location is one of the most
prestigious fly fishing areas anywhere
in the world it's a fisherman's paradise
there it is anglers lodge how on earth
could this place go wrong
look at that
gorgeous
hello
how are you good i'm savannah savannah
gordon nice to see you me too
wow
my goodness me this place is gorgeous
who built it my father no stop yeah
seriously their hands you are kidding me
wow
yeah it's all family business we're all
in it together wow um and recently my
oldest brother zach took over the
restaurant so zach's the restaurant
manager
is mum and dad around i'd love to meet
them i'll i'll follow you
wow
look at those beauties up there it's a
vegetarian nightmare up there yeah
let's fish everywhere yeah
the rural hello i'm david dede how are
you very nice to see you this is my
brother preston good to see you likewise
wow this is definitely a family-run
business right yes sir gordon how are
you the gentle giants with the midas
touch by looks of things uh
congratulations place is gorgeous thank
you thank you did you build it really i
did build it wow just had a vision in my
mind and we put things up took them down
until it looked right and do you live on
the property i do we have a cabin right
across the way just here yeah don't tell
me you built that as well i did
where was the conversation you both had
when you decided to go ahead and build
it we found this old beat up buildings
there was a for sale sign on the back
side of it so we made a deal and here we
are started building um what was the
dream duty what was the ambition well
you know we just loved love the
beautiful river we just thought it would
boom you know because of the beauty it's
really one of the most beautiful spots
in idaho right and people just loved it
so there was like a two hour wait
every night how long ago was that that
was our first two years wow like our
first two years that's a long time ago
so we got off to a great start what
happened then we
hired another chef and then people got
mad because we changed the menu after
that we had a
tragedy
after the tragedy my parents
just kind of checked out it was a really
hard time for my family and i think it
showed in the lodge you know they
couldn't put their whole heart into it
because their heart was broken so are
you in love with it as much today as you
were 10 years ago i'm very proud of it
and i love it but i'm really tired
right we've been here a long time you
know our goal is to have the best
restaurant in the area and 100 miles
around but
through the years we've just uh lost
interest in that and he's really tired
you know he doesn't want to work that
hard anymore right
so you're the
russian manager yes and where did you
train i worked at a few really nice
places when i was living in san diego
that was probably where i learned the
most oh so you went away and then came
back i've been gone for about nine years
yeah right okay i'm gonna get to the
room um pack um zach why don't you show
me to the room yes sir
oh
god it stinks no what's that smell of
lemon
i'm not sure got a smell of lemon
i mean why on earth would you need air
freshener in here with such beautiful uh
woof
yes the smell in here is crazy now i'm
just going to open the window oh i guess
the back of your throat right yeah it's
a little um someone going to make up the
beds
they are made i've seen dog baskets uh
better how old are they they put in
about five years ago bloody hell
seriously
yeah they're definitely old
is that blood i don't think so what is
that
i'm not sure
it's a stain anyway wow okay so um i'll
be down a couple of minutes for a bite
to eat sounds great yeah would you
recommend she does the rainbow trout
here what's her name her name is gina
okay great thanks the update pleasure to
meet you thanks zach
wow
the view is breathtaking
but
the color is depressing i mean honestly
everything's dark and gray and dingy and
the pillows look at those how uninviting
like the dog sat on it for the last 10
years i really do smell
what is that
it's like a piece of candy stuck on a
pillow
that's terrible it's almost like they've
fallen out of love
for this place and look at that
big dirty stain it's sad because it's
almost on the verge of being neglected
and you've got two owners that have
clearly run themselves into the ground
you think of a lodge in this area you
think of something that's cozy it's warm
in biting this is depressing
oh dear
always a great way to find out how often
the place is cleaned
check out the filters
oh dear
that's
that's 15 years of dust
[ __ ] in there
turn this thing off
it doesn't take much to clean that
hence the reason why this room stinks
of air freshener
[Music]
[Music]
hey how are you oh so nice to meet you
nice to see you too
what do you think's wrong with the
business
staffing issues
servers they're just constantly late and
you know i wouldn't have a manager but
zac's the manager yes he would come in
at three or four o'clock hey in the
afternoon yeah but is that dave's fault
is he tight uh does he not want to put
money into the business he wants to be
as thrifty as possible yeah you know
this is your menu
you're the chef so yeah i know so who
dictates this
dave he never let anyone do the food
orders even no chefs really but he's
controlling you yes and controlling the
business
tightly by the sounds of things yep
gina thank you thank you
does your dad realize when you build
something this unique
then you need to have a team to run it i
don't think so no i don't think he
realizes at all he doesn't know he
doesn't know one bit he's not he doesn't
let them order their own food
ah no he watches every penny is he that
controlling he really wants to watch
what's being
sent out and what's being paid for the
money
zach please
excuse me
thank you sir my pleasure
thank you very much
wings there for you sir with the
homemade huckleberry barbecue sauce well
thank you
now the wings fresh i believe they come
frozen
gina knew it's coming right mm-hmm yeah
you can't buy fresh chicken locally here
bean served frozen food wasn't the start
i was looking for it looks like it's
been
dipped in else blood
in fact the food just kept getting worse
pulling back that rib eye is like
pulling back that duvet on my mattress
that stain and
wow that's strong and alcohol he's a
good wine for this right all right
gina claims her hands are tied in the
kitchen so at this point i don't know
who to blame
that rice is mush
who cooked that
it's like oatmeal
what the [ __ ]
idaho rainbow trout with the herb
risotto jesus
what's all the uh squidgy bits around
the outside those are all the sauces
all the sauces yeah yeah seriously yeah
ah is that risotto or some of the
plaster that your dad left over from
building the new lodge
it's still got the scales on it as well
why would you leave the skin that's
soggy like some news condom
that has to be the worst trout i've ever
seen in my entire career
wow
does mum and dad see this food do they
come and have dinner they hate
everything
they hate the
the dish or
everything
they don't like the way that she does
anything then why is she here
when you're in the heat of the season we
kind of just take what we can get you
can't keep on changing your chef every
year i agree we do it every year [ __ ] it
now
if this place wasn't run by your parents
would you work here
hell no no not for a second
i don't want to run a restaurant how
keen are you to get out i i'm desperate
and if you got a job tomorrow would you
be off
yeah i feel like i've kind of done my
part the part that i told him that i
would do you're obviously concerned and
you're doing it more out of affection as
opposed that you really want to be here
sounds like your mind's made up
[Music]
wow
let's get them out please
would you both come out please all those
could you come out
both of you what if i don't want to
jeff ramsey nice to meet you likewise
good to see you too
wow uh so
i'm not for words
what feedback did you get throughout my
lunch
i didn't say anything you didn't say
nothing at all not yet course by course
you didn't even talk to them no why not
i figured that was what you were gonna
do when we were done i was hoping at
least you're gonna say something to them
so they can up the game no i actually
expect you to say something and i
thought well should i ask or i kept
thinking okay it must be okay i haven't
heard any comments
don't you want the truth oh absolutely
do you know the owners hate your dishes
no you don't know the owners
hate your food
no i did not know that
you've got no idea that
dede can't stand the curry no i never
knew that
i feel like people have been lying to me
tina i don't blame her let me i'm gonna
be frank
the ribeye was overcooked it looked like
we'd opened at the bottom of the
dishwasher and that plug was blocked
with bits of floating grease
oh my god
you may find it funny but you're not
sure i was funny the way you just
described it no but no i'm not trying to
laugh about the room no no but [ __ ]
out
look where we sat though
if you phoned me on my telephone in the
car and asked me what do you think i'm
gonna be having i would never have
mentioned those dishes you did nothing
to blow me away i'm trying to use the
ingredients that dave asked me to use a
lot of it is cost
so
i was tied to that
art you're the sous chef is there any
synergy in what you're doing no
you're just doing it to survive no one's
thinking long term
it's stifling the business
i'm amazed you're still open
zack i don't know if you've got one foot
in one foot out you shouldn't be here
yeah i've not been super invested that's
for sure get the [ __ ] out of here
[Music]
hi
so far i've learned that dave and dede
are checked out and zach just doesn't
want to be here tonight at dinner
service i'm curious to see if dave is
actually holding gina back in the
kitchen
um
so gina explain the line don't stop
working with it okay i work right here
in the saute area and then uh the
section doing the burgers the steaks and
zac he mostly stands behind the bar so
he's not the restaurant manager then
he's a barber he's supposed to be
he went from the bottom to the top this
summer nothing in between but you don't
get support from him doesn't know how to
doesn't know how to
what's the microwave for gina uh to heat
the dip up not my choice but not my
choice to do a lot of things wow you're
the chef right yes so what you say goes
no should be chef
jesus christ
[Music]
why
art did you make that no what is that
it's some kind of cheesecake
collapsed cheesecake looks like a man
mine what is that from like 1876.
wow
next ticket karina please
your salad will be right up full time or
part time
it's okay to chew gum in front of
customers or
dave just likes to go on
um
no it's very gross
and zach i know you can't tell staff or
two but uh this young lady's chewing gum
i just i don't know you're right yes no
i know but um
is
it's not typical no yes sorry yeah it's
not typical laura please choose spit
your gum out thank you
thank you are you okay yeah i'm crying
you sure yeah you're good what's going
on here yeah you're right she didn't
have done absolutely
excuse me just one second
what's going with the rib eye curry that
i'm playing with a second chef but don't
you talk to each other so the food can
hit the window at the same time if you
open up and talk to art then art can
take the sauce out the container and
heat it up in a pot yeah if you'll hand
it to me i can do it right here i got
lots of time i'm doing it man for a tiny
kitchen trying to expedite this food it
so never needs to be this hard you know
that gina
you don't like talking do you um it's
hard for me when i'm working i'm sorry
but you're doing desserts can't the
young man do the desserts yes i know
everyone tells me i need to relinquish
responsibility you guys are more capable
you can slice a cheesecake with these
nicely yes chef anyone can do it but you
prefer wasting time doing it yourself i
know just because it couldn't get any
worse
the problem with this lodge is becoming
more apparent there's just no
communication gina doesn't speak to the
kitchen dave and dd ignore the problems
and zach just doesn't know how to take
command
oh man it's so dysfunctional
yeah is a little cold
oh is it
what's she saying
the chicken breast
chicken is cold she would like a new
chicken breast sometimes absolutely
new chicken breast please
just stop for two seconds yes sir
exactly
art
but i just wanted to touch that
touch it it's ice cold it's old school
that's what we resulted in sending
you're just drowned way in over your
head a mess a big mess m-e-s
oh man
so i was underwhelmed and disappointed
you built this place
to the absolute spec beyond belief but i
was disappointed in my room
the beds terrible zack i pulled back the
top duvet and there was blood underneath
the duvet the air conditioning filters
were just full of [ __ ]
it was really shoddy
really shoddy and it broke my heart i
didn't even build the [ __ ] place
right
and look at the kitchen tonight
what i don't get
is the service and the offering
because it was shocking the chicken goes
out ice cold slightly pink and nobody
cares
and that
dreadful cheesecake well that cheesecake
collapsed when i left the kitchen rid of
it i i was i did today no you didn't
i know you're [ __ ] nuts
nuts
you wrote that menu gina i did you said
your hands were tied so you've got no
freedom um dave gave me
more freedom i believe than he's given
chefs in the past so sorry you have
freak i'm just going on what you've told
me i mean i'm not talking about chefs
listen you told me lunch time your hands
were tied and you can't buy anything you
can't talk to suppliers and what dave
says goes yes i mean basically dave do
you handcuff gina no i'm not handcuffed
her only thing i try to do is get her to
cost compare you've got to try to keep
food costs lower are you telling me that
what you're sending is value for money
it's
no it's not nowhere near it
am i the only one
that believes what we're doing is
incorrect
zach you're not a resident manager your
heart's not in it young man
and i asked you one vital question
lunchtime if your parents didn't own
this restaurant would you be here
and immediately hell no
i know we're in trouble
the lodges around here are more
successful they're much more successful
and they're not even
half as lovely
can i just have five minutes with you do
you mind okay
let's go uh
thank you
[Music]
this is on a deck of cards at the moment
that i feel it's about to collapse
because it's built with no
infrastructure
how's the strain of the business
affected you and dave
we've had a lot of really really hard
years you know a lot of arguing things
that i think are really important um he
doesn't and vice versa why is he so
stubborn in a way that he's so
overbearing and so controlling i think
he's just really scared of the
losing things so he tries to
watch everything you know and dave
wanted zach to kind of learn the
business so that
in case anything happened to him that we
didn't lose everything our kids didn't
lose anything all of our investment
right
and you probably know the terrible
things that we went through
well i disappeared right because i
couldn't function so
he did it all himself he'd run the
business without me and he
did the best he could and
he just did what he has to do and that's
what he does he does what he has
to do and he knew that i was gone and so
he
he ran up by himself
yeah
he needs to accept that he can't
continue like this
his heart might be in the right place
but his head's not in the game
you've got the view
the building's there but right now it's
just a shell
it's had better days for sure
really really good days are the first it
was wonderful
we need to get that back
[Music]
good morning good morning i came here
yesterday and i asked everyone to be
open and honest
and the first time i heard any honesty
last night was with your mother not easy
that is it
i um
don't condone your behavior
my behavior was what
i just felt like you're like the
language that you used wasn't that of an
english gentleman like i would expect
i'm deeply sorry about that what
language did i use a lot of f words
um i don't appreciate you using that
language with my angel of a mother and
my sister can i just stop you there
because you're over exaggerating a
little bit
because i'm not gonna give you brownie
points standing in front of your mother
telling me how upset you are when you're
laughing and giggling with me at the
same time
you see it as it is you have to call it
as it is i like the fact you're standing
up so it takes me to swear for you to
step up and act like a man
please you don't know [ __ ]
did you just curse
that's disgusting behavior young man if
you want to have a little chat with me
later together one on one i'd love that
but stop being a hypocrite
you've just sworn in front of your
mother that was a mistake and i
apologize mom
the hours you turn in four o'clock in
the afternoon i don't know how you can
call that a full day's work
gina was frustrated the fact you don't
commit staff get no direction and you
walk around shaking cocktails but i
don't need to prove to you my ass no no
ask you to prove it to me
your father put you in charge of the
restaurant so the big question is what
was your son zach doing here
my view was he was going to come
help me run the restaurant he's not even
getting any
feedback or talking to gina or even just
asking service to not chew gum yes it
concerns me a great deal okay
shall we move on i've got something
really important to tell you please yes
it's something that you're not familiar
with
it's called feedback
we're always here
i spent some time this morning just
traveling around driving thinking
contemplating and popping into local
places fly fishermen locals houses
cabins you name it i went there the sad
news is they don't want to come and sort
of
tell you to your face because it's a
small community
but i've got the feedback
my daughter had a wedding reception held
at the lodge we'd go back and celebrate
but over the years things have gone
downhill
dave makes us very very unwelcome and
he's pushed the town away it doesn't
feel like they want us there
the owner seriously well
needs help
he's a total horsey's butt he has no
idea how to handle employees or his
customers
there was a time the community rallied
around to help them but he showed no
appreciation so it didn't last very long
after time he was a jackass again
couldn't care less too bad so much
potential there
maybe they don't care
i don't know why everybody thinks i'm a
horse's ass i guess i am huh
i try to be friendly to people and i
treat them just like i treated you i
come across cold and
arrogant you come across controlling
and you come across assertive yeah
we need to get them on our side whether
we like it or not
their last comment to me
was that if you are prepared to change
and commit to change then they would
walk through those doors
uh dave i just want to spend a couple of
minutes with you do you mind okay um
thank you guys thank you
why does zach get so uh defensive like
that i think insecurity
maybe
um guys can you just give me give five
minutes please in fact let's go outside
in fact let's jump in the car
i mean
honestly
i'm here to help yeah
you come across so withdrawn
i don't know what to do about that where
did that level of negativity come in
well it started when i first broke
ground here and all the locals started
attacking us and trying to shut us down
you know you have to put your head down
and start swinging it but then you were
successful we were successful and then i
hired a shitty chef and then they all
took off and went away and then i found
a good chef and some of them came back
but i can't
please them all the time sure but it's
not all about the chef dave it's you
have to take part of responsibility
you know so these people leave um and
they let you down you know at the end of
the day that's on your shoulders right
yes
dealt with that tragic loss of your son
and that took her a long time
did you seek help when you lost your son
no did who did you talk to no one no one
you so you just came back into work yeah
the next day the next day there was no
one here
i mean how did you get through how
well and just get through
you know
you you go day by day time time helps
heal you know but there's a hole in your
heart that never heals
right yeah it's never going to yeah
but have you expressed this to dede and
that that's how you've dealt with it
because i think she's a little bit in
the dark i think she struggles to read
you
yeah maybe
i just deal with it by on a daily basis
you know there's not a day goes by i
don't think of my son and the loss but
you know you you move on you know i
still have to make a living i still have
to take care of dede's feelings and the
kids and all that you know the kids got
spoiled in the process because we
cuddled them a little bit and it's
obvious and zach's a product of that but
yeah you know i come from i believe that
they should
earn it yeah but i'm in a situation and
i have been in a situation where
my wife doesn't agree with that
philosophy so it's a constant friction
and same way with managing our
restaurant and our business she comes in
here and wants to cuddle employees and
doesn't expect them to hold to standards
and i come in and i try to get them to
hold the standards and i'm an [ __ ]
and we have conflict at home so
as a result of that i've tried to
minimize the conflicts and let zach deal
with the restaurant because that's where
most of our conflicts were the business
may have suffered i may have been an
[ __ ] on occasion
i don't know what to do about that you
know she she doesn't understand my
personality but i'm uh sometimes i take
no prisoners and it defends people
indeed he doesn't understand that
mindset she's more of a
off fluff you can't build this thing
like that
you're a
tough [ __ ] on the outside you have a
heart and you can show emotion
i have a big heart
then people need to sit
[Music]
i'd like to talk to you about something
that's
been missing
when you built this place we started off
so well didn't we yeah so i've put
something together that i think will
help reinstate that love yeah bring that
back to the forefront let's have a look
wow who's that there
look at that hair yeah
man what happened
look at that
wow talk about handcrafted
even the boys yeah they're going off
look how little they are yeah
yeah that's rare
dave smiley yeah that is real that that
would have freezed that one there
oh man
incredible
you know sometimes it's easy to forget
this is why you built this amazing lodge
for the family right did he yes
chokes me up yeah
look at that that's a picture i haven't
seen forever we need to frame that one
on the wall
[Music]
these are the most amazing pictures
beautiful
something quite magical about that first
fish right
didi
we see those amazing pictures what goes
through your mind
oh just
just the memories and dreams that we had
you know and everything just getting
better and better and better you know
and then just enjoying the property all
of our life right
it's a stern reminder to why you built
this place and just watching your face
light up reminiscing in some of those
amazing times it's so nice to see yeah
i didn't see it when i arrived
and that's what's been missing yeah
those were good times when we look back
at the pictures that are building the
place it brings back that
energy that we had then and it really
does mean something you know we had
we've we've raised the family here we've
we've raised our kids here all those
memories were good memories so it's
always been worth fighting for
for me
you need to
fall back in love with it
but more importantly with each other
yeah
how important
is this to you both
it's everything it's the world yeah it's
the world to us that's all we have when
it's done and said you know we spent our
best years building this place and
running it you're confident we can get
back there
you've got it in you
[Music]
yeah yeah
oh i feel so much better because now
we're
moving past all the bad things
and we're starting to take a look
towards the good things
after boosting the spirits of dede and
dave it was time to elevate the lodge
itself
my team spent all night working to turn
the anglers lodge into a destination
worthy of his rich family legacy
let's go i can't wait to show the family
what we've done
in you go please
oh
enjoy wow look at that come on jump in
[Music]
wow look at that
gone is that hideous blood color
um inviting
gorgeous
let's start off with that amazing
reclaimed wood
the bed spreads brand new oh i love it
new carpets just beautiful is it yeah
it's amazing i think you've uh you've
opened our eyes to where the place can
be and you've done a great job
it's amazing it was just like a new joy
kind of like when we opened it up the
first time it was like a brand new joy
it's something that we can reach for
after going through such hard times so
we know what to do now look at the
rocking chair
nice we wouldn't even want to leave oh
it's just beautiful
hello hi guys good you guys here to
check in yes great oh wow oh my gosh
hi alex how are you good to see you
you should see what they did to the
rooms today it's amazing
i've created a delicious new menu
perfect for this region and my team have
been training the staff non-stop to
prepare them for a successful re-launch
tonight here is our dinner menu i've
invited the locals back and a local food
critic so the lodge can rebuild these
important relationships and get their
reputation back on track everybody's
attention just for a second our critic
is sitting watching paying attention to
everything that's going on thank you
hello we just wanted to welcome you all
to the lodge and i hope you're enjoying
your evening and we appreciate you all
coming in and trying this again and uh
we'd love to have you back can't beat
the setting of course and from now on
our food's going to match all those
things so hope you're having a great
time very nice to have everybody back
okay welcome have a great time
one short ridge right up here
what are you doing
what are you doing for the short run
right right now it's going
three ribeye yes chef and then you're
doing short rib are we sending the
appetizers
look look at me
gina gina come here come here you're not
even helping yourself you're not talking
to me and you're just going into one
okay i'm gonna force you to talk
okay so
yeah
gina
are you okay i'm okay for you sure i
promise okay good again ask that you can
serve the soup all right would you
please
absolutely okay soup boiling we send the
soup with one nice kale salad so next up
art dress me a kale salad no no i've got
the salad salad okay why can't he make
the salads never has to be this
difficult you can't work on your own
i've worked on my own many times chef
gina gina come here
come here
are you listening are you giving up no
no no i told you you cannot work on your
own you just shout i work on my own all
the time
is it best you go now
no
you can't work on your arm
you're gonna sink this place
get a grip
okay it's not difficult
next ticket
um
yeah fyi in there tonight gina's
struggling yeah kurt stepped up out
stepped up uh but with a menu that easy
if your mind's not in that
uh you've got no chance
kale salad in the window table 26
seat one thank you is that for the uh
critic yes
did he season it
i did salt pepper
um art
take over please uh gina take a step
back art gina's on the desserts let's go
okay i got chicken in the oven
so were those three apple crisp in the
oven or you forgot they are in the oven
chef yeah uh danny reheating a dessert i
expect you to nail that's your table you
know that nice and gently yes sir off we
go
roasted chicken with the crispy skin
and we can't do a scoop of ice cream
no answer we can't do a scoop of ice
cream it's cold in the middle okay how
are we doing
stop
stop i want you to take your apron off
okay
art
take over please okay
how's my desserts
ready roll
it's not working is it i'm just nervous
no it's not working
you know it's not working
i'm not gonna shout i'm not gonna scream
it's just it's unfair it's unfair in you
and it's unfair in the lodge
you're sending
a short rib to a table that we haven't
even sent the status
you're destroying the lodge
i've got a critic that's just landed one
mistake like that and this place is
going to close heard understood i'd like
to finish out the evening and
see how it goes
it's not working if you're going to go
back in that kitchen what are you going
to do differently
what's the point
i want to keep working so that i can get
it down i'm not listening
you're not listening you're not even
you're not even prepared to take any
advice any help no it's been a long time
chef since somebody was telling me
exactly what to do and it's different
for me we can't continue like this
there's no point in fighting this yes
oh man
okay
[Music]
daily done dave gina she's just not up
to speed yeah if she can't work with
this menu it's not going to happen so
yeah the good news is art and curt
already up to speed already
yeah yeah that's good uh good feedback
for the customers incredible everybody
was very happy loved everything's
compliments all around not a single
complaint that's right any different
questions from the critic nothing
difficult at all no he was uh he's very
friendly very nice and just really
enjoying everything he's like this was
simple and it was beautiful it was
perfect awesome nice good night right
yeah you happy i am happy good very
happy
that's my life i'm just so happy to have
you that's so nice people back in here
yeah well i mean they're happy right
yeah that's the most important thing but
there's one tiny missing link
someone that
i've arranged for all three of you to
meet her background is extraordinary she
knows the area inside out and i've asked
her to come here
for a month and help
set this place up i want you to benefit
from her knowledge please welcome
emily brown oh how are you i'm emily t.d
pleasure zach nice to meet you zach hi
emily nice to meet you
welcome nice to see you
welcome well
good to see you um first of all she
knows this business inside out and she's
excited to work as a consultant for a
month and help set this place up for a
very very busy season yeah i've heard
all about you guys really excited to get
you guys where you really need to be so
welcome um i want you two to do
something you haven't done for a long
time i'd like you to take your dear lady
and go and have dinner oh nice that'd be
nice yeah tonight
zach's got a table for you all right
that'd be great excellent it's first
time i've seen them holding hands
[Music]
see dave smiling like the pressure's
lifted off
the love is rekindled for sure
and i'm really excited to have everybody
in island park start coming back again
and being excited about the lodge like
they were when we first built it
uh my time is done you're leaving
now
i am leaving now you guys have a great
spark here trust me you need to show it
don't stop
good night take care god bless
bye
thank you so much
here's to me and you man
cheers
yeah to a new lodge
wow what a nice
oh man
that's better
man that's cold out there
there's a [ __ ] handbrake
the gear stick on the steering wheel
i shouldn't drive
[ __ ] useless
man
[Laughter]
after i left the lodge
the family embraced the many changes and
is excited about the future
both dede and dave have rekindled their
passion you're doing good honey
we're a good team and are enjoying
working together to make anglers lodge
the place to be
once again